now that our code is inside a function
it has to be called otherwise it won't
work
so let's invoke our code right after we
define it now first I'm going to give
myself a little bit more space here so
you can see what I'm writing and if we
call display work and save it and
refresh the page
we can see that our work experience
appears right here hmm so James when you
wrote display work you didn't put an
argument you didn't pass in a parameter
that's pretty interesting why didn't we
have to use one well this function is
used in an object that's in the global
scope for the script meaning it's
accessible to the function which is also
in the global scope true well let's
imagine that we wanted to I don't know
for some reason add multiple different
work sections to the page then what
would we need to do that sounds like a
job for an argument if this function
took in an argument we could pass it
different work objects which would each
get displayed on the page you think we
should do that yeah I'm having a hard
time imagining why you want to do that
for this example I have a better idea
let's say you wanted to track where
users are clicking on your site we could
collect the cursor location every time a
user clicks on the page and send that
off to our analytics site interesting
let's see how that works